trying to sell a script with a
sympathetic character is a much better
business plan
than trying to
sell a script with an
unsympathetic character
why is it important for the main
character of a story to be sympathetic
well
this is controversial um
it's a sales technique
i i mean i hate to kind of
put it like that but again
i'm obsessed with stories that get sold
because like anybody
who's listening to this who might want
to
write something
um
i mean i guess there are people out
there i've run into them who they're
like oh i don't care if i sell anything
i'm just satisfying this artistic urge
and you know more power to them but
you know but i'm like you know like i'm
a father i'm a grandfather i've got
four kids i've got three grandkids i've
you know i've got a mortgage i've got
expenses like people it's expensive to
be alive
and if you want to really devote
yourself to screenwriting i want
and somebody's coming to me for advice i
want to give you advice
that can move the needle and and try to
help you
not just achieve your goal of writing a
script like i i
not anybody can write a script but
almost anybody could write a script
getting a script sold
is a whole nother skill set
so for me the idea of a sympathetic main
character
makes your script more saleable
so it's because people
i don't care what people say though yeah
i like good anti-heroes yeah whatever
it's like
yeah at the end of the day
the vast majority of people want
characters that they can empathize with
that are sympathetic that you're rooting
for them to achieve their goal
right that you know that's really kind
of what i mean by sympathetic it's like
you you want this character to
to achieve what it is they're setting
out to do you're rooting for them
because now you're emotional you as the
audience you're now emotionally invested
in the story
um i was just watching something what
was it i was just watching something the
other night
i wish
it doesn't stick in my memory because it
had this this flaw is how you're
watching the movie and where um i really
wish i could remember what it was now um
and where
two thirds three quarters of the way
through the movie towards the tv show is
a movie
and i look at my wife and i go do you
care
what this character is up to and she's
like no i know yeah me neither
i i i i it's because the character
just wasn't sympathetic it's like there
was nothing there for us to root for i
didn't want them to achieve their goals
right so
you know so it was just
you know kind of like one of these
things where
it's like yeah it got made obviously and
i mean things get made all the time for
all sorts of reasons
but
but if you want to break into the
industry you know you want to you want
to try to
stack the deck in your favor as much as
possible
and just in my experience
trying to sell a script with a
sympathetic character is a much better
business plan
than trying to
sell a script with an
unsympathetic character
and
i will throw a caveat on that is that
you also
you don't have to make every
you want to sell
selling a script and having a career are
two
entirely different things
right
completely
like i i would
i mean
and i'm not badmouthing them because the
the you know they're at all but you look
up you know if you look up sort of the
career trajectory
of um you know i think uh jeff arch who
uh who wrote sleepless in seattle right
um the original of it you know which
which you know kind of got you know got
rewritten by nora ephron but you and
then you look up the career arc
of um of len
i forget his last name but he's the one
who wrote cable guy who started that
whole
sort of like domino effect of spec
screenplay sales you know kind of back
in the day where he was one of the
people that's part of it um it could
have been shane black who started the
the the thing at in the mid 90s but um
but len
blanken on his name there's one
look up on imdb and and you'll see that
that it that's selling those scripts
which were great well cable guys not a
great script but it did
you know get made you know but
it it didn't
it didn't translate into
career
security
right so so the goal is not to
just sell a script the goal is to have a
career so so there's kind of almost like
a two-part kind of thing with this is
that you if you can sell a script you
you're better off
trying to sell that script with a
sympathetic main character but there is
something also to be said to write a
script
that's unproducable i know it's going to
sound strange and very contrary to
everything else i'm saying because an
unproducible script becomes memorable in
some weird way
so it's like that's part of building the
career this is part of feeding your
family right so you you can do both and
this is also why
you you i i
you know i say you like make it
derivative and make it fast you know why
going back to my if it if it's taken you
a year to write a script you're not
going to make it because if you can bang
out two of these scripts you know like
here's one the really sympathetic
character and here's one that
is this crazy script that's kind of
unproducible but super memorable um and
you can do both of those in six months
you you're building up this like oh my
god this guy's
this this person has got
depth and interesting things going on
right but i'm gonna buy this one but i'm
not gonna forget this one right i i i
got and this is advice i got from a
producer who's telling me that that
somebody
and i had this advice everyone was doing
research for my book um
i was doing
interviews with producers and this
producer
gave me this advice about about
everybody every every writer who wants
to have a career should write something
that's completely unproducible um
and he gave the example of
he had a script about whatever right
completely unproducible nobody would
ever make this movie but
many years after this producer read that
script he goes i never forgot that
writer i never forgot that screenplay
i'm relaying the story now right like
you know i don't know how many years
later 20 years later and i remember the
story so so it makes you memorable which
is what helps
build your career
um but
you want to also feed the family so
that's why you get to like the
sympathetic character part so you can
write have your unsympathetic characters
you know or you know you are i mean i'm
telling everybody that look you know you
want to have your little you know you
know artsy fartsy
you know
interesting screenplay great write it
after you've got some money in the bank
because you
sold something that people wanted
you know it's
yeah so that's to me that's why
sympathetic works
do you think that's sometimes a deciding
factor in in
how far someone will go is that they
think oh that i'm selling out but really
it's a necessary i don't want to call it
an evil but it's a necessary part just
as as
showing up on time or whatever you know
i don't know yes selling out i don't
know what selling out even means to be
honest i mean i hear it a lot it's like
i don't want to be a sellout
it sounds like an excuse to me
it's like well obviously unless you're
living in your parents basement you know
and you don't need money or you're
independently wealthy then that's fine
do whatever the hell you want but
assuming you want to
make money at this thing that you're
telling me you want to make money at
then
you're not selling out you're just being
smart
right it's like
i don't know like if somebody wants to
open up a pizza shop
and
you know and there's the absolute best
brand of tomato sauce that everybody
uses you know and everybody every pizza
shop that uses this tomato sauce
you know
everybody says oh the pizza's so
delicious and you go i'm not gonna use
that pizza sauce i'm selling out i'm
gonna be different i'm selling out okay
fine good luck with your pizzas pizza
shop you know i mean it's like so i
don't know what selling out means i'm
too busy trying to put food on the table
to worry about selling out and i think
from everybody you are so i encourage
everybody
move off of that right just don't hide
i know i'm sounding like really angry
i'm very angry right now don't hide
behind expressions like
selling out
to cover up
for
your
your
current inability to earn a living at
what you're trying to do
um
learn the skills and and work on it and
you know
you know read books and watch movies and
join you know online
you know uh groups or even you know
meetups you know and get together with
people who love
storytelling and movies as much as you
do and and don't take no for an answer
and keep
just saying why did that work and
somebody says oh i think it worked like
this and you say no scheckter you're
wrong tell me again tell me again
explain it prove to me you know like
really
approach it
you know approach it like every other
profession
where people you know like
you know are earning money and and being
professionals at what they do
and don't treat it like a hobby
you know and
you know it's like i don't know
what was it do doctors
say oh i don't want to be a sellout
you know did i do real estate agents do
you know
maybe
maybe they do people on wall street
you know selling out maybe
but um but in in this profession it's
just like
you gotta take care of business you know
so